40 year old rich hill turned 40 back in
march now when he came to spring
training he was still recovering from
that elbow surgery that he had over the
winter
and vargas will let it drop because the
runner didn't leave and they'll get a
double play heads-up play by vargas and
a huge mistake by casting era to come
ready to play hero
never left the batter's box
by the time he did too late the lefty
for the brew crew brett anderson yeah
last time
against the cubs at wrigley field he
picked up a loss four in the third he
started out slow but picked it up here
comes the one two
and that set of the air to center
another chance for it abby garcia who
will actually give way to ryan braun and
he'll handle it for out number three
miguel sanae coming off a good night
last night a couple of doubles and the
one-o pitch rip to left down the line
that's the base hit this will be a
double
as that ball bangs around in the corner
ceno will glide in the second base alec
contact left his bat at 111 miles an
hour no score bottom two miguel with
second one out rosario bats with a 1-1
count
and the 1-1 pitch a ground ball up the
middle base in right center cino's gonna
round third head home and score eddie
rosario drives in his 19th run it's an
rbi single it's a one-nothing twins lead
here in the second
ryan braun coming up he bounced to first
base his first time
turns on one deep to left field out of
line and it's gone
ryan braun a rope
tucks it inside the foul pole and the
brewers take the lead here in the third
nice short stroke by brony and he uh
hammered that one this question was
going to be fair
his first of the season and career
number 345
for ryan braun the brewers have had five
straight reach
against hill with two outs bases full of
brewers two strikes and two outs on
garcia
o2 again curveball hit in the left to
base hit one run is in here comes keston
here to the plate the throw is offline
kira scores and the brewers add two more
a two strike two run single off the bat
of avi saeel garcia and the brewers lead
it four to one
lead off man aboard and here's christian
yelich one two pitch
yelling swings and lifts one deep into
center field buxton going back climbs
the wall it's gone
dead center field christian yelich his
sixth home run of the year and the
brewers lead it six to one look out he's
coming on yeah two hits a walk
and lefty versus lefty knocks one out of
here to dead center
ryan braun christian yellow is putting
up some offense here in the fifth here's
visayo garcia two run single back in the
third runner at first and one away oh
0-2 pitch to garcia curveball hammered
out to left
deep left bye-bye baseball for abisael
garcia
garcia's second of the year it's a
two-run blast
and the brewers lead it eight to one
brewer's offense after being held
hitless
into the ninth inning in last night's
contest
not the case today they have
been alive and well
buxton
stop in the hole arceus showing off that
arm for out number two what a rocket arm
that was how about that play sets
himself
throws it as hard as he can right on the
money too the accuracy is the amazing
thing too look at bucks and he can't
believe it
that's just a terrific throw i mean on a
lot of different levels not just the arm
strength getting rid of it quickly
[Music]
anderson with a one-two to fargus he
struck him out as vargas loses the bat
and a 1-2-3 inning ready to debut here
tonight drew rasmussen yeah this guy we
saw him in the summer camp we saw him in
spring training just nasty stuff
fastball slider throws hard 0-2 to
miguel ceno and a strikeout of cino and
that's how you start your big league
career 99 up in the zone yeah good luck
with that
and three fast balls one slider
into runner at first adrianza
rasmus into the plate struck him out
swinging 99 on the outside corner
rack up a couple decays for drew
rasmussen in a clean seventh inning
adrianza on the mound for the second
time he pitched in a ball game last year
they've had double digit hits in three
of the last four games as hero will lift
one deep to left field a no doubter a
solo shot for casting hero
the fourth home run of the night for the
brewers they lead it 9-1
he just hammered that i mean not easy to
hit a ball out of the ballpark
what's that coming in at 65 miles an
hour maybe
driven to right
and gonzalez has a home run
the fourth home run allowed by knable
and gonzalez has his third and it's nine
to two
well no matter what the score is you
have good quality at-bats and even
though the twins are down by them eight
runs gonzales got a good swing it's a
home run
[Music]
that is a fair
ball so now around third he'll score
vargas holds up with a single
and he's got a pair of hits
he picks up his first run batted in
and in the whole backhand stab arcia a
good play to end this one tonight
brewers put nine on the board tonight